what I have here is a Rubik's Cube yes
yes
okay thank you so I think you're on the
tier list of YouTubers that if they were
in prison would be terrifying uh you're
up there with lock picking lawyer and
you and then I don't know who else is
there and Michael
in my head in my head I imagine that
like YouTubers you wouldn't want to be
or would want to be in a prison cell
with because that's just strictly
because of what they do yeah because of
what you do yeah I feel like I could be
pleasant impressive no you've been
pleasant but I would be terrified of
what you're getting up to yeah yeah
what I have here today is I would
definitely
be do like you don't need I know those
you see those prison documentaries and
there's like they show like the guys
just doing some weird stuff yeah so I'd
definitely be one of those yeah yeah I'd
be scared of having this album collected
like little pieces from my meals yeah I
I'd be I'd come back to myself you'd be
like do you smell almonds and I'm like
yeah no why is that good yeah yeah I
would do that what I have here is a
knife
by the way I think the mic needs to be
close to your mouth I was talking more
about cyanide oh yeah so we forgot to
mention before the podcast yeah you can
have us like be really close to the mic
I just speak really loud okay yeah that
works too that works that works as well
so yeah if you don't know Nigel Nigel
does chemistry videos on YouTube and
makes quite bizarre things I'd say yeah
you've definitely seen them on like
YouTube what's some of the greatest hits
yeah yeah when when someone recognizes
you what is the video that they always
bring up to be like oh you're that guy
from xvideo I think it depends real like
some of the videos are normal right yeah
like I just made it
I made things like just materials like I
made Arrow gel yeah like a super
conductor that was awesome those are
just like I'd say like oh yeah perfect
but I see airgel every day of the week
superconductors yeah you made uh gloves
out of grape or hot sauce yeah so that's
probably like for it's still just
chemistry so it's like a bit further
away from normal like the transition is
a bit odd
but I think the thing that people call
me out on that I'm always like huh is
like is the the stuff I did with p
ee well when you try to drink your own
pee
there was a Decay no okay okay there was
a bunch I've made probably
a couple full-length videos involving P
where I involved my own p and then
it's worse yeah yeah but and for one of
the long ones I did actually it wasn't
my pee I was in in in first p in part of
the we've actually talked to this on
like on my podcast before right with the
um
I did one on Diabetes yeah you're just
like early in the channel and a friend
was diabetic or is diabetic yeah but the
early way that they detected it was by
tasting it and to see if it's sweet what
so he yeah because there could be sugar
in it and so like when I first thought
of the video I'm like yeah I'll taste it
but I chickened out I couldn't do it you
didn't taste your friends pee no okay I
I couldn't do it that would have been a
pretty epic murder
I would definitely remember you for that
if you did that I was waiting for like
the I was waiting for the information to
match up there where you're telling that
story so so you're like yeah so I did a
video with Pete uh so how that started
is my friend was diabetic
um
why I decided to do that video I thought
it was interesting like just the whole
way that like um that's how it started
people didn't know what diabetes was
yeah yeah and then it was like some of
the early doctors I guess I think they
tasted people's blood they just like
it's I mean they they they did you have
to do what you had to do right must have
been like the biggest casualties back in
the day from just eating this [ __ ] and
just drinking people's hepatitis ridden
blood I think that yeah they definitely
like Peter cup and you just sit
not what I was expecting yeah like I
think diabetes like the full name
diabetes mellitus just I forget what
diabetes means but it means melodious
means sweet right it's like it comes
after like the taste so but then since
then obviously the goal was to to get a
method that didn't involve tasting me uh
so then there was a chemical method yeah
they found out how to test things test
for sugar with chemistry okay and then
that was not very useful so then they
started using like uh digital products
I just thought it was great
so I wanted to do a video on it yeah but
the one that I use my own pee was I
wanted to make there was a sweetener
that you can make from urea right right
in your piece yeah I collected a bunch
of my own pee I boiled it off in my
backyard
I'm assuming you don't use this like
saucepan anymore sorry did you use this
pen anymore oh I know it's probably long
gone okay I was gonna say yeah sell it
for some Goodwill someone else will have
a use for it I think the pee smell never
came out of it
after I use for that video just there's
just this musty piece there's there's
nothing more unpleasant sounding than
boiling pink you know it was the smell
so bad at the beginning right it was
like a hot summer day and remember I sat
there just I think I was like reading a
book called The Bee was just boiling
so you used in your backyard but you you
know it's back here oh my god
um you were the neighbor's kids yeah
no we did some stuff the neighbor I
don't think I could have the channel if
my neighbors weren't more tolerant right
wow you get a lot of stuff where they
just I remember one day I was trying to
distill Mercury I was doing it in my
driveway in your driveway yeah I had
like a full like I think I was I was
trying to be careful so I had like a
respirator on I had like a full coat and
everything oh my God and The Neighbor
comes over yeah and they're like what
are you doing and it's just like boiling
metal and I'm like oh I'm just selling
Mercury he's like cool
that's cool I'm like man I would not be
this cool yeah if my neighbor was
distilling Mercury I think I'd be like
hey government can you do something
about this guy he's [ __ ] he has to be
on a watch list he's got uranium in the
back and he's making uranium things I'm
kind of scared my neighbors and my
parents in general were just they just I
think Canada too just like the
government also doesn't seem to care I
mean maybe saying this you shouldn't say
that
claim